hello everyone
today i am joined by mike wilson who is
one of the founders of devolver digital
but has just recently announced a new
company called deepwell uh mike what
exactly is deepwell
uh deepwell is first and foremost a
video game company uh that's important
to note because about half the company
is made up of scientists and
medical professionals psychologists
friend people from the medical device
world that's not your usual video game
company
it's not it's not because uh
you know honestly devolver went pretty
well
yeah i think so
you did okay
yeah to be honest i was uh i was looking
to retire
and
unfortunately
or fortunately depending on how you look
at it
uh i was living up on vancouver island
in canada for
four years and i met this gent ryan
douglas who had just
sold his half of a much larger company
than mine a medical devices company
and uh you know we started talking about
things like
light sensitivity i was worried about
that moving to the pacific northwest
because i'm a sunshine boy and i know
that uh i tend to get sad uh if there's
not enough light so it's just
kind of organically talking to him about
that and wondering about vr
interventions uh because somebody had
told me he had done a lot of work in
light therapy and
sort of owned that market
and i was uh i was actually using one of
his little happy lights i don't know if
you've seen these little panels no
but essentially if you're somebody with
a scent that needs a lot of stuff
absolutely
i get
sad if i'm not around the sun for sure
yeah so well you're you live in uh
southern california yes okay
not as much of a problem but
i was living in austin and then i moved
to the pacific northwest and i was very
worried about this
for my family
yeah myself
and uh yeah there's these little lights
that you know you can set you know foot
and a half from your face in the morning
and soak up enough light into your
eyeballs to change your day you know
both in terms of uh sadness that some of
us feel we don't get enough light but
also just energy
like if i did this like past 11 in the
morning i would not be able to go to
sleep at night
whoa
yeah so i was a big believer in this
technology before i actually knew that
ryan had invented it
oh no way that's cool yeah and it was
just you know one of those lucky
conversations and we just kept talking
uh he was trying to retire as well we
just
neither of us are very good at it
and uh
we just kept talking more and more and
started talking more about you know i
had some friends that were making
meditation apps
and sort of digital psychedelics if you
will because i have a real interest in
uh breakthrough therapies in all forms
mental health and our and our lack of
answers for it has always been
a sort of passion of mine a sideline
um
you know for a lot of not wonderful
personal reasons relating to my family
and friends that have gone through
really hard times
and and honestly even at devolver i had
this a big wake-up call when i realized
that several of the independent
developers we had worked with
had been fully institutionalized like
while making their games or just after
finishing
and it really made me
i thought we were doing a pretty great
job of being a supportive publisher and
very artist friendly and looking after
our people making sure they're good
but that really made me aware that we
kind of needed to turn it up a notch in
terms of checking in on people
being aware of resources around the
world that we could point them to if
they need it
but also just really looking into why
this was happening you know and
and
you know as you well know game
development is a
a tough sport i don't know what you're
talking about it's easy
it's pretty tough even when you're lucky
enough to be in a uh a studio
like the one you're working in but when
it's one or two or three people working
on a game for you know two three four
five years
it's crushing yeah
and then the fact that you're also
expected to uh always be available to
interact with your audience
uh at any given time and to be perfectly
behaved 100 of the time
yeah and and
no artist in the history of making art
in any form has had to deal with that
level of
uh access for their fans yeah or critics
or audience and
i mean
if you've ever been to press you
you know well it's not the best thing
when you're already feeling at your
worst to be able to turn to twitter and
find a thousand people that agree with
you that you're a worthless piece and
that your work is meaningless etc etc
i think that's a big part of it and kind
of what set me on this journey about
five or six years ago into devolver
and i didn't really know what to do
about it other than speak openly you
know and every time i was interviewed
for i would say the last five or seven
years because i had spoken openly about
mental health issues a lot of
journalists wanted to talk more about it
you know because
they also have help
i think a lot of the industry sometimes
pretends that those don't exist and they
aren't a reality of working in game
development
absolutely so i i um i applaud you for
uh opening up the subject uh to your
audience and i think more and more um
content creators or just anyone with an
audience
or just among their friends in their own
community yeah need to speak as openly
about it as possible with a um
a sort of filter of curiosity about ways
to combat it you know and what we can do
and new things that are working for
people beyond the traditional
you know antidepressants or uh talk
therapy yeah so you so you met the
creator of happy light what did you
discover
uh well it's funny we were talking about
light and and he told me the dirty
secret of light therapy was
that all light is good for humans
in some way in the right amount and the
right doses at the right time like the
the the blue light that we're all
avoiding at night so that we can sleep
is wonderful for you in the morning and
you're trying to get energized yeah
you know everything has its place and
anyway we were talking about these
meditation apps and these digital
experiences and i was like the problem
with them to me is they're just not that
compelling compared to video games you
know you're not
they're not calling to you they're not
you're not lying they're thinking if you
can't sleep as i often can't about
getting up and playing that game some
more right yeah
and that's magic and and he started
telling me
about how that was the big problem in
his industry was doesn't matter what
they prove is good for people
we just don't have people to want to do
it yeah don't take care of ourselves uh
on a long-term basis very well
um we're just not wired to do things
just because they're good for us unless
we also happen to enjoy them no we or or
we need to do it for approval
instead there's a system at play there
and so we started doing some research
mostly him because that's his world
right he's very research oriented and
his whole family is
and started to find all of these studies
many of which
were
started with the idea of finding out why
games were bad for people
and ended up finding out exactly the
opposite fail their own hypothesis
yeah but you know and hats off to
scientists that are willing to reverse
their stance and say this is actually
what we found yeah and it turns out a
lot of games as they exist already
without the intention of being
therapeutic are quite therapeutic for
people
and
it turns out that when we're having a
good time
doing anything whether it's dancing or
at a concert or whatever it is if we're
having a good time for releasing
dopamine naturally we are much more
neuro-available to develop new neural
pathways to to learn new ways of looking
at things which is part of why uh
psychedelic assisted therapy has been so
successful
especially with like veterans and people
with severe ptsd
rape victims
that are not they're just not being
reached by traditional means and
for the government even under trump
to rush through these breakthrough
therapies because they were reaching
people that couldn't be reached you know
they're quite effective right especially
something as controversial as using uh
incredibly illegal drugs to get people
there yeah
so
so the thing is even before this
pandemic started the need was far beyond
our solutions like we had twice as many
people that needed help as we had
therapists and doctors to wow i didn't
know that damn yeah that was before the
pandemic now it's four times worse than
that
yeah
anyway uh
we started you know just kind of
bouncing back and forth we weren't
really talking about starting a company
yet but
at one point i was like ryan i think the
dirty secret about video games is that
most of them are actually good for you
because
with my own experiences of being trapped
in a story when you're depressed
just focusing on anything that takes you
on a journey gives you feelings of
achievement feelings of connection
uh which
game design inadvertently does a great
job of
ryan refers to it as an observational
science that's been perfected over the
last four decades
while i don't think any game developers
were really that's an interesting
outside perspective
well yeah because what we were studying
is what brings people back right what is
a compelling experience what is
something that um wants to make you
stick with it and finish it especially
you know when there are a thousand games
a month coming out or whatever it is
what makes something special
and and it's just that it's just
watching and playing and understanding
what compels you right and that's
so hard for us even that have worked in
the industry or our whole careers as i
have
to put your finger on what that is you
know but a great game designer or great
game team
just intuitively knows it from
experience from their own experience in
playing from watching people play things
like that and and and the entire medical
community has never been able to solve
that problem ever right so they know
that they dedicate their entire careers
to coming up with solutions and proving
them in clinicals over five or ten years
writing all these papers and then
the truth is people don't use the vast
majority of them
even medication by the way
less than half the people
that raise their hand and say i need
help and are and are lucky enough to
have access to be able to get medication
or get to a doctor
less than half of them still take their
medication once they get them and by the
way that's not just depressed people
that's people that are taking heart
attack you know pills to save their
lives
against medication
yeah we don't like to feel broken right
and we don't we don't again it's it's
it's really mind-boggling it's
fascinating in a way because
we're pretty well wired to take care of
other people
you know
especially you know our friends our
family especially if you uh if we have
children we're really wired to take care
of them like to to lay ourselves on a
train track to take care of them but we
just are not wired to take care of
yourself very well
and so
that's why all these scientists and
doctors and i mean
our chief medical officer is literally a
neurosurg a pediatric neurosurgeon who
will spend 18 hours in a child's brain
operating
and then come back to us and give us a
bunch of hours for deep well because
they believe in this so strongly
um because for them this is the holy
grail if they can come up with therapies
that are both effective
that are easily accessible for people
will actually do normal prices and that
people will do because they're enjoying
themselves mm-hmm so that was the thing
that uh
got ryan and i to say well
i guess we're not retiring
i respect it it's passion that kept you
in the game it can be hard to retire if
you're a passionate person it's
definitely a good cause so
what what exactly is deepwell planning
to do
okay so good question
there have been a lot of articles
written about us thankfully but still a
lot of people don't really understand so
i found three things that that help
people understand the first is we will
green light fun produce publish video
games just like devolver does
but those games will be
greenlit and fun and produced
because we believe that they will they
can tie to a therapeutic benefit that we
will help define
and we've built a back end technology to
help uh based on some
some
patents that ryan filed long before i
met him that just issued and he assigned
to deepwell
on how to be able to make creative
iterative software
uh in a way that the fda can understand
it and and verify and validate the fact
that you're doing what it says it does
without stifling the creative process
which has always been a problem in the
past
so
we'll create some original games and
we'll publish them we will also work
with other publishers and developers
that have games in development
that either they reach out to us or
reach we reach out to them and say hey
we think you're already doing something
great here there might be a few tweaks
you could make if you're interested
that will allow this game to actually be
certified as a
fda cleared medical device for treatment
wow that's so cool
yeah and then this is what's really cool
alana we realized that a lot of games
that are accidentally good for people
that weren't created for that reason
uh because of the system we've created
and the methodologies that are now
patented and we have other patents
pending we'll be able to go to
publishers and developers of games that
have been out for 5 or 10 or 15 years
and go hey do you mind if we demonstrate
the way in which your game is already
quite therapeutic
and so that we can steer people to it
for that reason
and in in the beginning
these games will be found in all the
existing game stores
because we can't you know we certainly
can't ask people to
leave steam or leave playstation or
wherever it is that they play
but suddenly you might play a game that
you already loved and the next time you
install it has a patch that tells you by
the way this game has been cleared for
the treatment of you know whatever the
indication is that's really exciting
it's really exciting and and then
eventually uh our longer term plans are
we will be creating a platform of games
there are a way to guide people to games
that are just looking for that yeah
they're only looking for uh experiences
that are going to be a benefit to them
and and that they'll be able to measure
on their way in and out you know sort of
how they're feeling how they're doing
what's working for them
and to do that we really need a wide
range of games because um
just like nutrition or medicine not
no one thing is going to work for for
both you and i right
especially with something like
depression which is this sort of stamp
we we give people
um
when they've reached a point of not
being able to help themselves or being
stuck
and but we all arrive there for very
different reasons right and very
different circumstances and what will
help us get through something
uh will be different and that's why we
we're excited to work with a lot of
external publishers and developers not
just whatever we can create ourselves
and yeah so it's really it's it's a new
way of looking at media you know media
nutrition or entertainment science
you know however you want to put it
because i think most of us know that
we've gotten through a hard time at some
point in our lives through a great book
or a film or a record that we play until
it you know
back in the days of cds until we broke
the cd do you know the witness the
jonathan blow game
audience will have heard me say this
before but uh i completely credit that
game for helping me through depression
almost 100 because i
i had pneumonia so i couldn't go out and
i had just moved countries i didn't know
anyone i was absolutely miserable all i
did was have my codeine cough medicine
and play the witness every day but i
looked forward to it because it was
something that that was pretty that
sounded nice that was very mentally
stimulating and gave me a sense of
accomplishment when nothing else could
exactly you know and we got a ton of
feedback um
i'd been talking with ryan for about a
year when fall guys came out from
devolver and
it was a global sensation literally
overnight
and we got so many letters and like
every game developer has
it's to some level but this one was by
far the most we had ever gotten of
people saying
my god this game gave me a lifeline you
know and it was at the height of
lockdown especially in europe like
really hardcore curfew style lockdown
yeah
and uh so many people you know some of
them living literally in spaces with no
window
and they couldn't leave you know and
they were they were
terrified for themselves
and that was really that last kick i
needed to go okay dude
you know too much to not put it this
plainly and it is a reality that i feel
like anyone who works in the industry
knows all the people who play a lot of
games know that games have helped me
with mental health issues a number of
times it almost seems nuts that nobody
has tried to do what you're doing before
um and i guess i want to ask is part of
the goal to have
you know something like video game
therapy be available to people in
hospitals or um absolutely
and you think that that's something that
the medical community will entertain
it's already happening um
the first game cleared by the fda came
out last year from a company called
akili it's a game called endeavor rx
that was cleared for treatment of adhd
no way for adolescents
um
they did it very differently than what
we're doing
but
you know hats off it was a long like a
decade long journey for them to get the
first
game cleared
i know that vr can be really good for
people who have autism or asperger's who
have trouble like reading certain social
cues
yes
people are using it for uh preparing
people for major surgery to keep them
from freaking out in the hospital
because that's one of the biggest
dangers for anesthesiologists or
surgeons
is that when they
when they try to put somebody under or
they go to do this procedure the person
is so freaked out already yeah that
their their system their body is
fighting against what you're trying to
do right and so yeah i've seen posts
from uh
nurses you know saying that imagine you
walk in and you're preparing your
patient for major surgery and they're
already chilled out or distracted
because they've been looking at
something beautiful in here
and a vr headset or whatever instead of
listening to all the beeps and yeah
wondering where their doctor is trapped
on a table
and so uh vr while you know it wasn't
quite the uh explosion that a lot of
people thought it would be in the game
space when it hit a few years ago
it's
the medical space is using it quite a
bit and so are lots of other business
enterprises
um
you know for things like you know you
might have the best surgeon for what you
need is in australia
but your team is in santa monica and
that surgeon can participate on that
team virtually yeah like so things like
that and if you just look up digital
therapeutics in general it's an industry
that's exploding but people aren't
really using it
for games um per se and certainly not
game first
and that's that's what i need people to
understand about deepwell is we
the scientists the regulatory
professionals the lawyers everyone
understands
that the magic is coming from the game
designers the game developers and we are
all in service of that which is
not unlike how devolver kind of flipped
the script with the publisher developer
relationship and said everything we do
is in service of you the artist right
and even if we fund something all the
way
we're doing it because we believe in you
and you have final say over everything
because what you do is magic
what we do as publishers is like
marketing and some are better than
others but it
there's no one on our team at devolver
that wouldn't
wouldn't tell you the same thing that
what we do versus what game developers
do is we're not on the same planet
it's nice to hear that when you when you
check that that basic ego check of who's
the
who not not the
both sides of that relationship aren't
important but one side is more important
and if you just acknowledge that and
accept that i believe that's why
devolvers had such an incredible uh
string of successes with indies
just that basic that one idea that we
are there to support them and not the
other way around
and when i heard these doctors and
psychologists and lawyers and everyone
saying singing that song to me that they
understand that that's when i was like
okay well now we can do something
because we can empower creators to do
what they do
and just to do it with perhaps a little
bit more intention or knowledge and
science backing
of how powerful the medium can be
it's nice to hear somebody trying to use
technology and like
some of the
digital addictions we can build to do
something positive because right now we
spend a lot of time looking at screens
but a lot of people are like doing it to
get angry on twitter or watching like
rage bait youtube videos
and that that is about intention like
the only people i believe
and i'm not speaking on behalf of deep
well or devolver or anyone my personal
belief
is the only people really utilizing the
power of games or the people using it to
addict people
uh
you know it's certainly a thing
yep and social media the same thing
anytime where their goal is to get as
much of your time as possible yeah they
don't care what you do with the time or
how it affects you mentally and that's
kind of what you're competing with which
i'm glad somebody's trying
that that is the intention but we can
flip that on its head and and use
intention to deliver people therapies
that can be truly life-changing
perspective changing new neural pathways
so that next time you're about to have a
panic attack you don't yeah you know
it's life-changing and you can only do
that um by
we're not good at uh
tackling these things with our conscious
minds it has to be taught to your
subconscious and to do that
you need to be having fun that's the
shortcut right
so it's super exciting and it's it's the
only reason i'm doing it you know it's i
i i've accomplished as much as i think i
ever set out to in games and
from the publishing side of things
like my job was to try to fix the
publisher problem i think you did a
pretty good job
well we
the team did because i assembled a great
team and with that basic philosophy or
the that the creators of the important
ones here but here's one more
interesting thing i want to mention is
it's not just the intention of the
creators it's the intention of the
player as well like why am i coming to
this game and what might i get from it
and that i relate a lot to like
medicinalizing cannabis
you know there are a lot of people
sort of self-medicating um without much
science or information for for a very
long time with that plant
um
and then now that there's science around
it and it's legal and you can actually
go into a dispensary and legally say
this is my problem i can't sleep or i
have chronic pain or whatever that's not
about getting high and they can give you
the medicine you need
that's what i believe can happen with
not just games but other media i do
think games are the most powerful
because they require you to engage and
participate
whereas
linear
media you know you can just sort of zone
out or be doing two or three other
things yeah
and just making you focus on something
is a huge part of the battle yeah you
can you combine that with something that
you enjoy
um and then you combine some intention
around that and i think the sky's the
limit with what we can do well i'm sold
this all sounds great
great to me too i've enjoyed talking
about it you know the more i talk about
the more i'm like yeah you're selling
yourself
yeah
that's awesome um so what what's next
for deepwell what should people look out
for
yeah so
we've we started development on our
first game and we'll have games coming
out sometime next year but this is
really not about us and about the games
that we create internally or the games
that we green light and this is about an
invitation to creators to understand
their power in a new way and i thought
you know coming from devolver and and
and the joy of working with these little
indie studios all over the world we
thought the best way to start would be a
global game jam
and so that's what we're doing
just to reinforce the fact that
the story of us the story what we're
about is really an invitation for
everyone to think about
why they're making games
how they can make them better or more
beneficial for people and how just the
fact that that's an option
in your media consumption
just like anything else you consume a
lot of some is better for you than
others depending on your own
background and perspective and sometimes
physiology
and so the global game jam we partnered
with them and they just have such an
amazing reach
to all corners of the globe and i think
that's important because
we haven't really tested this yet
we will but but i my instinct is that
people from um
specific perspectives or cultural
backgrounds will make things that are
better for people from that same
cultural background perspective
and i love the diversity of the creators
in indie games because they don't have
to have a giant studio full of it
doesn't have to be this
massive endeavor and so you can really
take chances and um
you know we've all seen the results of
that from the last 10 or 15 years of
things that we never would have
considered you know in big studio
settings
um so yeah i'm super excited to see how
that goes and what comes with it can
people get involved
uh you can go to our website which is
deepwelldtx.com
and you can register there okay
and a lot of people have already
registered from i announced this at the
end of my uh gdc talk and it was
it was wonderful to see a lot of people
registering already even though we
really didn't define the theme or what
the prizes are
but the prizes will be significant and
the the theme will be based on science
that we can point people to studies to
to have a look at and to hopefully come
up with concepts related to those
studies that we would have never
considered
and uh that more information will be
leaking out over the next weeks and then
the the jam is a three-week jam
it's may 1st to may 22nd and it's we've
announced that it's you know mental
health based generally but we'll be
giving a bit tighter parameters for the
jammers to know uh how how
what their best chance to win is you
know like what how how they should be uh
working
and uh these these three week jams i
didn't even know they went that long i
always thought of a game jam it's like a
weekend it's how you minimize people
crunching on the jams though yeah
well we've been we're so lucky we have
kate edwards on our team who just
resigned as executive director of the
global game jam and so she she knows
this stuff pretty well
and uh she's leading this jam for us
and she said the longer jams the two or
three week ones really result in a lot
you know it gives people time to really
think through what they're doing it's
not
a mad rush so you get more polished
experiences and hopefully some things
that are worthy of you know green
lighting to full production you know
it's exciting
yeah i'm stoked about it i love game
jams in general i love indies so
i'm not sure you know i hope big studios
start working on things like this as
well and yeah
but for now i think indies are the
perfect place to start and because we
need a wide range of experiences yeah
from different perspectives i think that
makes the most sense i definitely agree
uh well thank you so much for chatting
to me i appreciate it this is all like i
said very exciting to me i feel
very strongly about this i like went
through a breakup a while back and i
played through abzu
and uh it's the same thing where i just
like gave myself therapy and that game
was so nice except the time that i
turned it back on there's this one part
where you have this like conflict with a
shock that's really sad and i like
didn't know that's what i was heading
into but it was like such a beautiful
like indie game to
to play through for that kind of thing
so
i'm definitely absolutely definitely and
sometimes depending on what you're going
through uh sunshine and lollipops is not
what you're looking for that's true
i just played on memoir blue which i
think is devolver as well um and came
away from that
game like oh i have some things i need
to think about
exactly right yeah i didn't expect that
before i played it
that's right and that that's the holy
grail right we and we don't want people
only playing our games because they feel
broken uh these games have to be as good
as anything out there and we want people
not
looking for that necessarily or maybe
they're not ready to acknowledge they
need that sort of help
like yourself just playing it because
you heard it was good or it looked
interesting and then finding
that it benefited them in some way and
we've all been doing that with games and
music and books film our whole lives
there's just never been science around
it so i'm so excited to put to change
that you know and
and uh hopefully we'll start a trend and
and similar to what devolver did where
several other companies said we are also
a devolver we will also do business in
this way and we um that's that's the
hope is that we get a whole lot of other
companies saying yeah i'm interested in
that let's learn how to do that together
um because it's really you know it's not
about how big we get or how successful
we are it's about just getting people to
think about this medium in a new way
it's very exciting i am very glad that
you are working on it thank you um is
there anything else you want to mention
before we oh that's it i just i want to
thank you again for uh using your voice
you know to start these conversations
it's important
and i hope that more creators will
follow suit i know that a lot already
are
um but yeah it's
there's
nothing more important there's no bigger
crisis on this planet right now to be
honest and
that's that's saying something
cool well thank you so much um i will
leave a link in the description to where
people can find out more about deepwell
and sign up for that game jam and i will
also watch it closely i'm very excited
to see what people come up with
thanks for joining us mike
thank you see you all next time bye